.
Wenn ich mir auf
Instagram Yoga-Posts anschaue,
frage ich mich, wurde das
jetzt mit Selbstauslöser gemacht?
Oder war das ein
organisierter Foto-Shoot?
Ist das alles nur ein Hype?
Oder bringt Yoga wirklich was?
Hat Yoga gesundheitliche Vorteile?
Körperliche wie psychische?
Die wirklich wissenschaftlich
nachgewiesen sind?
Die Forschung hat
mich ziemlich überrascht.
Neben der Theorie gibt
es natürlich auch einen Praxistest.
Mit unserer
rasenden Reporterin Saadet.
Ola, ola, Senorita. I'am back.
Sie nennt sich selbst...
- Depp für die Wissenschaft.
Für uns hat sie drei
verschiedene Yoga-Arten getestet.
Welche davon die beste ist,
was die Wissenschaft dazu
sagt, das klären wir jetzt.
Was ist Yoga überhaupt?
Wenn ich an Yoga denke,
denke ich an pure Entspannung.
Karibik-Musik, Wellenrauschen.
Ich und mein inneres
Ich, wir finden zusammen.
Ich dachte, Yoga,
da legt man sich so hin.
Wenn man versucht, eine kurze
Definition von Yoga zu finden,
dann stellt man fest:
Das ist natürlich
ein sehr weites Feld.
Das ist Holger Kramer.
Er ist Psychologe
und Forschungsleiter
an der Klinik für Naturheilkunde
und integrative Medizin in Essen.
Naturheilkunde
und integrative Medizin,
das klingt für eine
08-15-Chemikerin ungewohnt.
Aber da ich bei meiner Recherche
auf einige interessante Studien
von Holger Kramer gestoßen bin,
dachte ich,
ich skype einfach mal mit ihm.
Yoga, wie es
heute meist praktiziert wird,
umfasst vor allen Dingen
die bekannten Yoga-Haltungen.
In sehr unterschiedlicher
Ausprägung, das kann sehr sanft sein.
Bis sehr sportlich.
Oft sportlicher, als es scheint.
Ich dachte, ich wäre nicht
die unsportlichste Kartoffel
auf dem ganzen Planeten.
Da waren Übung bei,
die waren sehr schwierig zu halten.
Und die andern sahen
dabei alle so entspannt aus.
Ich nicht, ich bin
richtig ins Schwitzen gekommen.
Neben dem Bewegungsaspekt
umfasst Yoga auch spezielle
Atem- und Meditationstechniken.
Yoga kann total viel umfassen.
Wenn wir nach Indien gucken,
hatte Yoga früher eine
starke spirituelle Konnotation.
Es stammt aus der indischen
Philosophie und Spiritualität.
Es ist durch
den Kontakt mit dem Westen
auch in Indien sehr stark
zu einer Gesundheitspraxis geworden.
Gesundheitspraxis.
Holger Kramer untersucht
Yoga als Zusatztherapie
bei verschiedenen Krankheiten.
Was steckt dahinter?
Spannend ist die Forschung
zu Atmung und Gesundheit.
Man könnte meinen, Atmen ist eine
so grundlegende Überlebensfunktion,
was kann man da schon
viel falsch oder richtig machen?
Wir atmen manchmal
zu flach, zu schnell
oder zu viel durch den Mund.
Vor allem, wenn wir gestresst sind.
Es ist etwas dran an der Empfehlung,
bei Stress erst
mal ruhig durchzuatmen.
In einer Prüfung oder
vor einem wichtigen Vortrag.
Dass Atmung nicht nur Luftholen ist,
sondern Einfluss
auf unser Nervensystem hat,
ist inzwischen
wissenschaftlich ganz gut belegt.
Wenn man sehr speziell
in die Atmung eingreift,
wie es im Yoga der Fall ist,
kann man relativ viele
physiologische Systeme beeinflussen.
Bestimmte Atemtechniken
können Neurotransmitter
im Gehirn stimulieren.
Zum Beispiel:
Das ist ein Neurotransmitter,
ein Signal-Molekül.
Das Gehirnsaktivitäten
runterregelt oder hemmmt.
Die hemmende Wirkung ist
ziemlich wichtig für unser Gehirn.
Dass wir aktive
Gehirnzellen brauchen, das ist klar.
Aber auf der anderen Seite
sind wir so vielen Reizen ausgesetzt,
dass es sonst
eine völlige Reiz-Überflutung wäre.
Wir wären gar nicht mehr dazu
in der Lage, Informationen zu ordnen.
Oder zwischen verschiedenen Reizen
zu differenzieren.
Diese Hemmung braucht
unser Gehirn auch, um zu verhindern,
dass Schaltkreise
im Gehirn übersteuern.
Und sozusagen eine Rückkopplung
entsteht. * Rückkopplungsgeräusch *
Das passiert nämlich
bei einem epileptischen Anfall.
Deshalb werden bei Epilepsie
auch Medikamente eingesetzt,
die die Gaba-Konzentration erhöhen.
Dass Yoga über die Atemübungen
und die GABA-Erhöhung
auch gegen Epilepsie helfen könnte,
dafür gibt es bisher keine
belastbaren wissenschaftlichen Daten.
Doch GABA hat viele Funktionen.
Es hilft uns nicht
nur bei der Konzentration,
auch bei der Entspannung.
Deshalb spielt es
eine Rolle bei Krankheiten,
die mit Stress in Verbindung stehen.
Etwa Bluthochdruck.
Stress senkt den Gaba-Spiegel,
Yoga kann ihn wieder erhöhen.
Yoga kann zwar nicht
alleine eine wirksame Therapie
gegen Bluthochdruck sein,
aber als Zusatztherapie
zu konventionellen Methoden,
zu entsprechenden Medikamenten,
kann Yoga durchaus helfen.
Dazu gibt es einige
randomisierte, kontrollierte Studien.
In denen Yoga als Zusatztherapie
den Blutdruck weiter senken kann.
Unsere Atmung kann auch unsere
kognitiven Leistungen beeinflussen.
Es gibt ganz neue
Forschungsergebnisse, die zeigen,
dass Atmung unser Gehirn
zum Schwingen bringt.
Lange glaubte man,
dass diese Schwankungen
Hintergrundrauschen sind.
Aber jetzt hat man gezeigt,
dass Atmung die Aktivität
der gesamten
Großhirnrinde synchronisiert.
Und dass diese Aktivität
unserem Atemrhythmus folgt.
Diese Studie zeigt,
dass Atmung sogar unsere
Merkfähigkeit beeinflusst.
Die Studienteilnehmer bekamen
in der ersten Phase des Experiments
180 verschiedene Bilder zu sehen,
für je eine halbe Sekunde.
Die sie sich
möglichst gut merken sollten.
Nach 20 Minuten Pause
bekamen die Teilnehmer
in einer zweiten Phase
wieder ganz viele Bilder gezeigt,
und zwar eine Mischung aus
den bereits gezeigten Bildern,
aus Phase eins, und neuen Bildern.
Die Teilnehmer
mussten die gemerkten Bilder
unter den
neuen wiedererkennen.
Es ist voll krass,
es stellte sich heraus,
dass die Teilnehmer in Phase eins
sich die Phase dann
besonders gut merken konnten,
wenn die Bilder zum Zeitpunkt
des Einatmens erschienen.
Vor allem, wenn die Teilnehmer
durch die Nase einatmeten.
Abgefahren, oder?
Diese Studien belegen natürlich nicht
die Wirksamkeit von
Atemübungen beim Yoga.
Aber sie zeigen
überraschend deutlich,
dass Atmen mehr
ist als nur Luft zu holen.
Deshalb ist es zumindest plausibel,
dass man beim Yoga versucht,
Entspannung oder mehr zu gewinnen,
indem man Atmen bewusst übt.
Dass Atmen geübt sein will,
das merkt man schnell,
wenn man sich mal an einer
Atem-Meditation versucht.
Bei der Atem-Meditation
konzentriert man sich
ganz auf seine Atmung,
auf das Heben und Senken
von Bauch und Brust,
auf die Luft, wie sie ein- und
ausströmt, und auf sonst nichts.
Und das ist schwieriger,
als es klingt.
Anfängern empfiehlt man zum Beispiel,
ihre Atemzüge zu zählen.
Damit man nicht so leicht abschweift.
1, 1.
2, 2.
Sobald man in
andere Gedanken abschweift,
fängt man wieder von vorne an.
Macht das mal
und schreibt in die Kommentare,
wie viele Atemzüge
ihr geschafft habt,
ohne an etwas anderes zu denken.
Es ist erstaunlich schwierig, hier
konzentriert zu bleiben.
Am Ende verrate ich euch
noch eine weitere Atemübung.
Die könnt ihr dann in
Stresssituationen anwenden.
Aber gehen wir jetzt erst
mal von Atem weg, bzw. weiter.
Was ist mit den ganzen Yoga-Posen?
Welchen Zweck haben die eigentlich?
Zunächst einmal ist Yoga Bewegung.
Und je nachdem, welchen Kurs
man belegt, auch richtig Sport.
Da Saadet ja sonst
sportlicher unterwegs ist,
hat sie sich drei verschiedene eher
sportliche Yoga-Kurse rausgesucht.
Einmal traditionelles Ashtanga Yoga.
Es war eine super angenehme
Atmosphäre in diesem Yoga-Studio.
Wir kamen da rein, da lief ein
bisschen Musik im Hintergrund.
Alle waren super nett und lieb.
Haben auch irgendwie
schon so leise geredet.
Das war ganz ungewohnt für mich.
Es war gar nicht so
einfach, wie ich gedacht habe.
Zwischendurch habe
ich mich voll entspannt.
Aber es war auch echt anstrengend.
Dann einmal Hot-Yoga.
Wir haben im Raum 39-40 Grad Celsius.
Und einmal Aerial-Yoga.
Auf die gehen wir
gleich noch genauer ein.
Dass Bewegung gut ist, wissen wir ja.
Bei chronischen Rückenschmerzen
ist Bewegung eine
konventionelle Therapie.
Physiotherapie oder Stretching.
Hier hat sich gezeigt,
dass Yoga mit den konventionellen
Methoden ganz gut mithalten kann.
Also eine ernst zu nehmende
Therapie-Alternative ist.
Aber Yoga ist nicht nur eine
Art Sport oder Bewegung.
Macht es ein Unterschied,
ob ich bestimmte Asanas ausführe?
Oder irgendwelche
Gymnastik-Bewegungen mache?
Zumindest kann man, im Vergleich
zu vielen anderen Sportarten,
feststellen, ...
dass die Yoga-Übungen
oft gar nicht so intensiv sind.
Dass man oft in einem Bereich ist,
wo man sagt, es reicht noch nicht,
um es als Herz-Kreislauf-Training
zu klassifizieren.
Es ist eine zu
geringe Intensität, um zu sagen,
dass Herz-Kreislauf-System
wird genug angeregt.
Um zu sagen,
es ist ein wirksames Training.
Es wirkt aber trotzdem.
Wir haben trotzdem eine Reduktion
von Herz-Kreislauf-Risikofaktoren.
Irgendwas muss
da drin sein, was noch wirkt,
wenn die Bewegung eigentlich
gar nicht intensiv genug ist.
Einen ähnlichen Effekt
stellte Holger Kramer fest
bei einer Studie
zu Yoga und Gewichtsabnahme.
Wo wir zeigen konnten, dass durch
Yoga übergewichtige Teilnehmerinnen
Gewicht reduzieren
konnten, Bauchumfang abnehmen.
Wenn man das mal ausrechnet,
ist das alles
gar nicht intensiv genug,
um wirklich eine
Kalorienreduktion hinzubekommen.
Dass diese
Gewichtsabnahme sein dürfte.
Es scheint die Meditation,
verändertes Essverhalten,
Achtsamkeit,
das scheint eine Rolle zu spielen.
Der Bewegungsaspekt
lässt sich also schwer von
anderen Yoga-Aspekten trennen.
Aber vielleicht ist
genau deswegen Yoga so positiv,
weil es nicht nur Bewegung
oder nur Meditation ist,
sondern einen gesamten
Lebensstil beeinflussen kann.
Der potentielle Anwendungsbereich
von Yoga als Therapie
ist jedenfalls erstaunlich groß.
Wenn man bei
Depressionen guckt, weiß man,
dass Bewegung bei
Depressionen generell gut ist.
Es gibt auch gute Hinweise,
dass Meditation bei
Depressionen gut helfen kann.
Sodass Yoga als Kombination
auch wieder recht naheliegend ist.
Wenn wir in sehr schwerwiegende
neuropsychiatrische Störungen kommen,
reicht Yoga wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber im Bereich der Depression
haben wir sehr gute Hinweise
mit sehr starken Effekt-Stärken.
Bei leichten depressiven Störungen.
Bei einer
manifesten majoren Depression.
Da ist Yoga wahrscheinlich
nicht sonderlich wirksam.
Auch der Einsatz bei Krebs-Patienten,
bei Brustkrebs-Patientinnen,
wird viel untersucht.
Wenn man sich Krebs anguckt,
Yoga wird nie zur
Behandlung des Krebses eingesetzt.
Die Studien drehen sich immer
um Symptome der Krebserkrankung.
Oder auch mit Nebenwirkungen
der Chemotherapie umzugehen.
Yoga hat also Potenzial
als Begleittherapie bei Krebs.
Es geht um Milderung von
Nebenwirkungen oder Symptomen.
Um ein gesteigertes Wohlbefinden,
um Stress-Reduktion.
Viele Krebs-Patienten brechen
tatsächlich ihre Therapie ab.
Weil sie die Nebenwirkungen
nicht mehr aushalten.
Wenn man es schafft,
diese Nebenwirkungen zu mildern,
dann kann das über den
Therapie-Erfolg entscheiden.
Dieses Problem haben wir schon
bei unserem Video über den
Placebo-Effekt anklingen lassen.
Deswegen denke ich schon,
dass der Grundansatz dieser Klinik,
konventionelle Therapien anwenden,
aber durch Zusatzmethoden,
wie zum Beispiel Yoga, zu ergänzen,
dass das durchaus wirksam sein kann.
Dass es so
viel Yoga-Forschung zu Brustkrebs
und nicht zu anderen Krebsarten gibt,
das liegt übrigens
nicht an der Krebsart an sich,
sondern daran, ...
Dass die typischen Yoga-Nutzer
meist jüngere Frauen sind.
Was häufiger die Population ist,
die an Brustkrebs erkrankt.
Sodass dort auch einfach
eine höhere Nachfrage ist.
Frauen mit Brustkrebs
nutzen Yoga und fragen Yoga nach.
Mehr als ältere Männer mit Darmkrebs.
Die fühlen sich durch Yoga
nicht so angesprochen.
Generell ist Brustkrebs
in vielen Bereichen
deutlich besser untersucht
als andere Krebsarten.
Von den Patientinnen
gibt es sehr große Bewegungen.
Es gibt sehr
große Selbsthilfegruppen.
Die auch Forschung, gerade
in dem Bereich, einfordern.
Es gibt viele Studien
zu Yoga und Gesundheit.
Aber was mich echt stört,
dass die meisten
methodisch ziemlich schwammig sind.
Das ist ein ganz
wunder Punkt in der Yoga-Forschung.
Es ist in der
klinischen Forschung das Ideal
des doppel-blinden
placebo-kontrollierten
Medikamenten-Trials.
Treue Freunde der Sonne wissen,
wovon Holger Kramer spricht.
Man kann in Yoga-Studien
natürlich Kontrollgruppen haben.
Man kann Teilnehmer vergleichen,
die Yoga-Stunden bekommen,
mit welchen, die keine bekommen,
aber natürlich bekommt
man hier keine Verblindung hin.
Nicht wie bei
Medikamenten und Placebos.
Wo die
Studienteilnehmer nicht wissen,
ob sie einen Wirkstoff bekommen.
Außerdem sind die
Yoga-Interventionen,
Art und Weise,
wie Yoga angewendet wird,
von Studie zu Studie unterschiedlich.
Die Yoga-Intervention
hängt sehr stark vom Zentrum ab,
wo es durchgeführt wurde,
vom Yoga-Lehrer, der dabei ist,
auch von den Wissenschaftlern,
die eigene Vorerfahrungen haben.
Da haben wir sehr
unterschiedliche Yoga-Formen.
Es ist schwierig, wenn man sagt,
wir fassen alles zusammen.
Deshalb kann man von dem
aktuellen Stand der Yoga-Forschung
nicht davon ausgehen,
dass eine positive Wirkung
auf konkrete
Yoga-Posen zurückzuführen ist.
Vielmehr muss man davon ausgehen,
dass Yoga, als Form von Bewegung,
ähnlich wie andere Formen
von Bewegung, gesund ist.
Hier jetzt auch noch
gepaart mit Stress-Reduktion
durch
Atem-Übungen, Meditationsübungen,
und wahrscheinlich auch einem
allgemein entspannteren Lifestyle.
Was ist mit
so krasseren Formen wie Hot-Yoga?
Beim Hot-Yoga begibt man sich in
einen 40 Grad Celsius heißen Raum.
Mich hat der Schlag getroffen,
als ich in den Raum gelaufen bin.
Man ist gegen eine Wand gelaufen,
weil es so warm da drin war.
Schon nach den Aufwärmübungen
habe ich geschwitzt.
26 bestimmte Asanas werden in
einer bestimmten Reihenfolge gemacht.
Jetzt den Arm nach oben,
den Arm nach unten...
Das war richtig
schnell hintereinander.
Meine erste Stunde,
deshalb war ich überfordert.
Ich hab ständig die Sachen nicht
da hingekriegt, wo sie hin mussten.
Ich habe mich verknotet und
währenddessen sehr viel geschwitzt.
Entspannt sieht das
jedenfalls nicht aus.
Saadets Trainer erklärt uns,
dass der Anfang zwar schwer sei.
Aber durch das
Verinnerlichen der Reihenfolge
und den strikten Ablauf,
da käme man in eine Art
meditativen Zustand.
Es gibt einzelne Studien,
die zeigen können,
dass Hot-Yoga wirksam ist,
bei Patienten mit Herzerkrankungen.
Dass es
die Elastizität der Gefäße erhöht.
Dass es Symptome verringern kann.
Die Studien haben
allerdings methodische Mängel.
Die würde ich auch
durchaus hinterfragen.
Für mich ist es
bisher nicht überzeugend,
dass es wirklich Herz-Kreislauf-
förderliche Wirkung hat.
Ich wäre auch durchaus vorsichtig.
Das medizinisch vorerkrankten
Patienten zu empfehlen.
Ich empfehle sowieso
nicht, mache nur Forschung.
Aber ich würde
Kollegen auch nicht raten,
speziell Hot-Yoga zu empfehlen.
Dafür ist die
Datenlage einfach zu gering.
In dieser
kleinen Studie ließ man Teilnehmer
drei Monate lang
Hot-Yoga praktizieren.
Damit meine ich die 26 Asanas.
Einmal in einem heißen Raum.
Einmal in einem
normal temperierten Raum.
Die "heiße" Gruppe hatte zwar nach
diesem Experiment weniger Körperfett.
Aber in Sachen
Gefäß-Gesundheit und -Elastizität
fand man keinen Unterschied
zwischen den beiden Gruppen.
Allerdings sah man bei
beiden Gruppen eine Verbesserung
gegenüber der Kontrollgruppe,
die gar kein Yoga machte.
Sollten sich diese Ergebnisse in
weiteren Untersuchungen bestätigen,
hieße das,
dass die kardiovaskuläre Wirkung
von Hot-Yoga gar nichts
mit der Hotness zu tun hat.
Was mit Sicherheit bei
hohen Temperaturen besser geht,
in gewisse Yoga-Haltungen
hineinzukommen.
Dass man vermeintlich flexibler wird.
Man ist gelenkiger und kommt
besser in schwierige Yoga-Haltungen.
Wobei das aber wahrscheinlich
ein Trugschluss ist.
Dass man gar nicht
wirklich gelenkiger wird.
Sondern einfach nur der
Widerstand geringer wird.
Und man die Gelenke
genauso überlastet.
Wenn man in den Lotus-Sitz in normal
temperierten Räumen nicht rein kommt,
in stark erhitzten Räumen
würde man reinkommen,
weil das Gewebe
ein bisschen beweglicher wird,
ist die Belastung
für die Hüfte genauso groß.
Wenigstens wurden bisher
keine gefährlichen Nebenwirkungen
oder Risiken
von Hot-Yoga festgestellt.
Solange
man gesund ist und genug trinkt.
Junge, gesunde, sportliche Menschen,
die können das mit
Sicherheit mal ausprobieren.
Gut, dass Saadet jung,
gesund und sportlich ist.
Doch es muss ja
noch nicht mal Hot-Yoga sein.
Nur weil es entspannt
aussieht und entspannend ist,
muss es nicht frei von Risiken sein.
Holger Kramer beschäftigt sich
in letzter Zeit vermehrt mit Risiken
und unerwünschten
Nebenwirkungen von Yoga.
Es gibt eine ganz
spezielle Warnung bei Yoga.
Für alle, die unter einem
Grünen Star oder Glaukom leiden.
Beim Grünen Star liegt eine
Abfluss-Störung im Auge vor.
Der Augeninnendruck
erhöht sich immer mehr.
Beim Kopfstand, beim Schulterstand,
da ist nachgewiesen,
dass sich der Augeninnendruck erhöht.
Dass Patienten mit
einer Vorgeschichte von Glaukom
dadurch eine
Verschlimmerung verursachen können.
Was bis zur Erblindung führen
kann, also nicht trivial ist.
Davon abgesehen gibt es beim Yoga,
genau wie bei anderen Sportarten,
eine Verletzungsgefahr, wenn
man die Bewegungen falsch ausführt.
Die Verletzungsgefahr hängt gar
nicht so stark vom Yoga-Stil ab.
Das Power-Yoga,
eine sehr intensive Yoga-Praxis,
die eher als Workout genutzt wird,
hat ein etwas
höheres Verletzungsrisiko.
Ansonsten sind die relativ ähnlich.
Aber das Verletzungsrisiko steigt,
wenn Leute vorher nicht
bei einem Yoga-Lehrer waren.
Wenn man Yoga nur durch
YouTube-Videos lernt,
dann ist die Verletzungsgefahr
deutlich höher,
als wenn man es
wirklich von einem Menschen lernt.
Soviel könnt ihr aus
diesem YouTube-Video mitnehmen,
YouTube-Videos helfen nicht immer.
Was ist mit
speziellen Sachen, wie Aerial-Yoga?
Saadets beste Freundin und meine
Funk-Kollegin Lisa-Sophie Laurent
macht regelmäßig Aerial-Yoga.
Sie hat immer davon geschwärmt,
wie cool das ist.
Dass das Spaß macht.
Dass ihr das hilft,
im Alltag runterzukommen.
Deswegen hatte ich große Erwartungen.
Ich kam da rein,
es war ein Riesen-Studio.
Da hingen so Seile.
Ich dachte: "Alles klar."
Ich hoffe, ich breche
mir hier heute nicht das Genick.
Zu Aerial-Yoga gibt es,
wie ihr euch sicher vorstellen könnt,
bisher gar keine Forschung.
Wahrscheinlich wird sich
das so schnell auch nicht ändern.
Es ist generell ein Problem,
dass es kaum Gelder
gibt für Yoga-Forschung.
Viele dieser Studien sind von
privaten Verbänden finanziert.
Wie zum Beispiel vom Berufsverband
der Yoga-Lehrenden in Deutschland.
Und das sehe
ich natürlich sehr kritisch.
Wenn Interessensgruppen
Studien unterstützen,
gibt es immer die Möglichkeit,
dass Interessenskonflikte auftreten.
Was wir immer machen,
dass wir das Studien-Design,
die Studien-Auswertung,
Interpretation, Veröffentlichung
komplett bei uns liegt.
Der Berufsverband
in keiner Phase der Studienplanung
und Auswertung mitredet.
Über die Studie hinaus haben wir
kein persönliches Interesse daran,
ich bin kein Yoga-Lehrer,
verdiene kein Geld damit,
wir veröffentlichen größtenteils
in konventionellen Zeitschriften.
Wir stellen uns der Begutachtung
der Kollegen, der Kritik.
Viele dieser Studien sind
in angesehenen Journals publiziert.
Und wurden auch von anderen
Wissenschaftlern geprüft.
Es spricht zumindest
aus meiner Sicht nichts dagegen,
es einfach mal auszuprobieren.
Dass Yoga, richtig angewendet,
Stress reduzieren kann,
so viel kann
man sicherlich festhalten.
Und dann ist es auch gut,
dass es so viele
sehr verschiedene Yoga-Formen gibt.
Wo jeder seinen Stil finden kann.
Von sehr spirituell
bis zu sehr sportlich.
Denn wichtig ist,
dass man eine Yoga-Form findet,
an der man langfristig Spaß hat.
Eins hat Saadet sicherlich
aus ihrem Selbstversuch gelernt,
nach einer Yogastunde
ist man noch nicht Zen.
Welches von den drei
hat dir am besten gefallen?
Das ist schwierig, nein,
jetzt sind die anderen sauer.
Aerial-Yoga war am coolsten.
Es hat auch Spaß gemacht,
diese Übungen auszuprobieren.
Das Team war auch super.
Aber alle waren nett.
Ich habe gelernt,
alle Leute,
die Yoga machen, sind nett.
Das ist mein Learning.
Ich finde, die Yoga-Forschung
zeigt vor allem eines:
die Wirkung scheint
nicht an bestimmten Yoga-Arten
oder Yoga-Posen zu liegen,
dafür ist Yoga viel zu vielfältig.
Es geht hier vielmehr um einen
Lebensstil, um Stress-Reduktion.
Um Achtsamkeit, um Bewegung,
um gesündere Ernährung.
Das kann man mit Yoga
sicher hinbekommen,
aber bestimmt auch anders.
Sei es durch Sport
oder regelmäßige Tee-Zeremonien.
Schreibt doch mal in die Kommentare,
was für Erfahrungen
ihr mit Yoga habt.
Oder ob ihr irgendwelche
anderen Freizeit-Tipps habt,
für ein entspannteres Leben.
Dann können sich die
anderen davon inspirieren lassen.
Und wenn ihr Vorschläge habt,
was Saadet in Zukunft als
Selbstversuch testen kann,
dann schreibt es bitte
auch gerne in die Kommentare.
Unter dem # stuntsaadet.
Und jetzt kommt
noch die versprochene Atemübung.
Ihr seid in
einer stressigen Situation,
wollt ein paarmal tief durchatmen.
Durch die Nase,
euch auf den Atem konzentrieren.
Weil das nicht ganz einfach ist,
helfen euch eure zwei Finger.
Ihr könnt immer abwechselnd
ein Nasenloch zu halten,
durch das andere konzentriert
tief ein- und ausatmen.
Diese kleine
körperliche Hilfestellung
macht es viel einfacher,
sich auf den Atem zu konzentrieren.
Wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr eure
andere Hand auf den Bauch legen.
Und darauf achten,
dass die Luft richtig rein strömt.
Dass sich der Bauch hebt und senkt.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Bis dahin, bleibt entspannt.